[Music]
welcome everybody to the bee don't choke
thanks Pete
friendly guy everybody relaxed friendly
guy
wouldn't it be disappointing if I
weren't a friendly guy if that's all
whoo whoo if that all just an act the
second I walk offstage I'm just like I
said iced tea
but no I'm a friendly guy I love making
friends too and some friends you're
friends with immediately immediate
friends I love that a fast friend but
the truth is real friends deep
friendships that happens slow even if
you hit it off with somebody right away
your first hang out you love them right
away
if they immediately start referring to
you as a bestie just although is that
all the red flags is that all of them I
believe that's all of the red flags I
mean this is true there was a guy I hung
out twice I hung out with him two times
and at the end of the night he said to
me you're my real family Pete yeah me
and the brood of mannequins you eat
dinner with every night yeah
sociopath for a friendship to be a real
friendship it needs to grow it needs to
go through several phases I figured him
out first is the initial encounter phase
this is where you're just getting to
know somebody your first meetings your
first kind of judging each other book by
its cover stuff that's fine you're just
coming yeah the vibe I like the vibe
like it's vibe I like this guy honest
kind eyes it's got a Galifianakis beard
t-shirt has an owl on it I like that
seems like a good time and he just
ordered a martini at 10:00 a.m. I mean I
can't see us not having a great time
boom that's what I'm looking for
apparently I'm just looking for a
homeless guy with an owl t-shirt
and aren't we all and then there's a
couple of hangouts later there's the
sharing common interest phase this is
where you get to comb each other to see
what you like if they like it it's the
same thing anything that overlaps going
through their CD collection like oh my
god I also have two copies of Jagged
Little Pill just in case right also
you're the only other guy I know that
buys CDs are you homeless that makes you
comfortable with each other that helps
out and that helps bring you to the next
phase which is one of my favorite the
shit-talking phase does anything bond to
people faster then talk and whoa
that's real friendship right now that's
the glue for friendship but you can't
with a new friend
you can't come right out right another
gate all fists and elbows just like your
second hang you know the dildo
you can't Brian Brian's a giant dildo
that's too risky that might scare off
your new friend so you got to you got to
drop a couple subtle hints you know what
I mean a little invitation to talk
just like hey you notice that I Brian
well he got kind of weird when we
brought up the whole secret santa thing
and it feels great when he's just like
yeah cuz Brian's a dildo
complete your friendship is cemented in
the mutual understanding that brian is
indeed a giant dildo and now you're
close and that brings you to the soul
bearing phase sharing a couple scotches
in the kitchen opening up sometimes I
just feel like the last piece of bread
in the bag and that's an opportunity
how's the friend gonna react is he just
gonna hear you and be like you know what
can you do or is he gonna hear you and
be like man we're all bread just waiting
to be toasted even though that doesn't
make any sense at least you're like
that's comforting now you know they're
there for you they will help you out you
can calm at any time just like our house
I ate a live crab I'll be right over
now comes the final phase my favorite
phase the ballbusting phase this is the
true test of friendship we've loved
we've shared the sailings been smooth so
now it's time to rock the yacht a little
bit with a few insults be like hey roses
nice jeans I didn't know they made
Levi's in a wash called horrendous
[Applause]
but he's a real friend he doesn't even
care or Flynn she's just like yeah big
words from a guy with Gary Busey teeth
real friends now we're cooking with gas
baby that's a friendship nothing worse
than a guy that can't take a joke that's
a deal-breaker
if he comes back like excuse me what
these jeans Peter are not Epping
horrendous they're classic cut blue wash
timeless denim ageless look that guy
that guy can't be the best man at my
wedding
that's the kind of guy that will get up
there and give a sincere toast look just
say you both inspire me Julie you look
radiant Stefan real friends break
balls I want the guy that's gonna roast
me right after my vows come out and be
like none of us knew how this limp dick
got Julie but he did it raise a glass to
limp dick someone's gotta raise tonight
you
[Music]